[Musik]
sonst so ärgerlich aber ärgerlich nicht
okay hallo leute ich sie da noch mal ran
und bekam seinen neuen look bahn wohl
aber ihr seid auch hier setzt euch daran
tisch in kürze story warum also lassen
wir hatten hier schon so ungefähr 20
minuten lang aufgenommen ohne
aufzunehmen ohne aufzunehmen
gut unterhalten
wir wollen die ganze sache machen und
sonst kann man eine kartoffel das team
habe ganz blockiert war
also ich esse jetzt erstmal noch so
ich hoffe noch über die gleichen waffen
ja das ist so ironisch
wir haben wir haben seit gestern
zusammen unterwegs wenn die gewisse
extra nicht über social media geredet
weil es unser thema ist damit wir jetzt
vor der kamera authentisches er darüber
reden können was du brauchst eine kamera
an zu machen zwei reichen
aber die jetzt im blick aufgefallen dass
die kamera mit mir also und hat so ganz
kurz zum frühstück wir haben hier ganz
viel obst salat marmelade
wir haben eine wunderschöne avocado
haben wir entdeckt die das die
wunderschön ist wir haben auch noch
joghurt und aufstrich aufstriche ich
habe eine ski die latte von starbucks
response
ich hab die veganen ausschnitt habe ich
noch nie gegessen ist sehr lecker und
wer will was er sagt scheller style und
übersah dabei den gibt alles ewig aber
der laden was haben wir noch gesagt ich
habe irgendwann es gemacht und jetzt hat
folge lag bestimmt
vielleicht ja noch aber einfach drauf
macht mich das zu viel des guten
aber heute geht es um das thema social
media dienste bild gemacht
wenn's historisch vermesser hat es ja
nicht mehr
liebe presse wie geht es dir dann wird
mir gibt mit instagram oder instagram
geht's mir besser
es ist ja jetzt schon vier wochen her
seit wochen habe ich dann ins oder mehr
und ich habe gedacht ich würde mehr
leiden und mehr dieses sucht gefühl
haben diesen entzug war das anfangs
stärken
es war am anfang niemand der so
plötzlich auf zu rauchen der alles
auseinander brechen sagt ich habe
gekocht
der später so war das bei mir gibt diese
app gelöscht hatte sofort freiheit weg
eindruck all diese bilder posten die ich
nicht machen möchte und und dann kam
jetzt so ich glaube in der letzten woche
zu eingeschlichen dass wenn ich andere
leute sehe mit ihrem handy auf instagram
dann bin ich schon so dass ich mal rüber
gucken kannst du da noch mal wie beim
anhalt zu bei mir gestern auch ganz
genau wie instagram us-papiere wir
hatten wir haben das gepostet können wir
mein interesse davon angucken und bitte
ganz kurz wenn sie das den ganzen ablauf
instagram zusammen abgehangen
was macht ihr heute am dienstag beim
unterwegs einfach ein bisschen surfen
als auf dem iphone und so ein handy
hätte ja so die treue freundin allein
handy ständig von meiner mama deutsche
bekommen
[Musik]
der kredit super super die häuser kurz
bevor jung aufgehört was quasi mit dem
thema also dass er dieses jahr jeden tag
ein bild gepostet ja dass man eine
challenge wir wissen noch bekommen warum
stimmt darüber unglücklich schwamm warum
warum habe ich das übernommen master
soto verzichten
war das so ein bisschen ist dass man
sagt immer du musst jeden tag mindestens
ein bild kosten oder am besten 23
um erfolgreich als integer zu sein
ein spiel wie ich glaube ich wollte
immer ich wollte immer das sieht also
ich bin ja nicht nur die lustige war
nichts und ich bin hier nun nicht nur
dass er die immer gekocht war für heldt
soll das tram rausgekommen shine bright
black diamond wobei ich warum wir das
gemacht hast also ja weil die leute
kennen mich als lustige vanessa ich bin
vor der kamera super so sagen das auch
die zuschauer bei punkt dass ich bin die
quirlige lustige aufgedrehte und dass
die ernste das ist witzig und ich dachte
weil ich finde auch damit wie finde so
viele instagram accounts so schnell weil
die frauen sind so schön und schaust du
es an nichts
die wollte ich auch so sein das schön so
schön dass die leute nicht mit mir
lachen waren sondern hast du mir
freundin war es nicht schön aber dann
habe ich irgendwann gemerkt dass ich das
absolut nicht geil finde wenn ich die
ganze zeit jeden tag muss jetzt noch
waschen kriegs jeden tag eine nachricht
da bist du hübsch bei euch liebt dich
wissen ja dann jüngere leute die das
schreiben die älteren scheine dass
veganer
aber ich frage mich auch mal was mit
einem macht weil die bekomme echt viel
kommentaren feedback und ist natürlich
kritischen manchmal aber auch einfach
nur glück ist schön dass ich nicht ich
habe es ganz viele kommentare du bist
ungeschminkt so schön
das haben wir uns gefreut aber letztlich
ist auch was macht das mit einem mann
ging es heute sagen dass man mal schauen
welche ja aber wenn er es doch sagt
fühlst du dich denn dadurch anlass jetzt
kommt die sonne wieder jetzt richtig
hell who bist hübsch
[Musik]
ich glaube es den leuten nicht dass
dinge ist negative kommentare kommt viel
schneller bei mir an als positive und
das ist so verrückt also sag ich klinge
mal war das so führen auch viele dass
die unter dem video taucht mal lesen
kannst super lustig toller schnitt die
dritte und dann dahin ja ich habe es gar
nicht so dass ich das ist mir echt zum
tag auf vermiesen können und das ist das
was ich wo ich gearbeitet was ich nicht
mehr will dass ich wirklich weil es doch
scheiße wenn nur die gleichen guten tag
herr kommentaren wie muss die ganze in
ruhe darüber nachdenken und das zieht
sich dann auch christian einfach nur
eine person etwas kommentiert also dass
und dann darauf solche distanz
aufzubauen weil wenn du halt wie jeden
tag mehrere hundert kommentare
vielleicht kriegt dann ist das halt kann
theoretisch jeder tag heißen
mülheim eine schlechte genießt irgendwer
musste man die erste stammt also ja es
ist glaube ich auch sehr sinnvoll
die anderen söhne grundstimmung für sie
aufzufangen
aber andererseits ist auch so ich habe
schon immer etwas mache ich so sein
kommentar
gelte aber anders ist es halt auch das
was youtube ausmacht so das muss man
halt diesen austausch hat mit den leuten
dass du nicht entfernt die sammlung und
dann sagst du hier ist mein produkt
macht damit was ihr wollt aber andere
das ist auch diese app finde ich auch
ganz gerne wenn man sagt so er ich habe
das beste video gemacht hier ist es
meike donna eyecatcher und nach dem
motto von andere verschiedene ich finde
halt die kommentare braucht manchmal
total inspirieren
ja oder man die ideen ich kriege die
sind durch ein kommentar ist wo ich dann
legal jahren kümmern dass da aber ich
bin voll bei dir dieses das ist mein
video und man muss aber auch sagen die
meisten negativen kommentare weil man
kann negative kommentare kriegen oder
kritik ich lese aber sofort immer raus
niemand ist der mich eigentlich gut
findet und sagt das war irgendwie
komisch dass warum hast du das und was
gesagt
der ton macht halt auch die museen hat
halt genau die gleiche sache in zwei
ganz verschiedenen also kein ganz
unterschiedliche unterschiedlich bei mir
ankommen 1 verloren
wie die formulierung ist etwa eine woche
social media docks gemacht und darf wird
sich so mal fotos eine freundin zu
schicken und nicht die halter auf
instagram zur post normale post sondern
meine story version dann soja der wende
hier guckt an oder nicht
aber diesmal hat dann wirklich so in
vanessa so bilder vom urlaub geschickt
guck mal ich war das erste mal dass
werden so bilder geschickt haben die
nichtraucher geschickt das eine bild
springer ja und das ist auch so dann
nimmt man sich dann so teilt und seinen
freunden irgendwie was hallo zu sagen ja
du weißt anhalt in dem moment nichts
mehr weil sie möchte dass ich es sehe
und die soll es wieder weg wenn ich mir
ein bild schickt dann ist es halt für
mich dann ist es nicht so weit kommt mal
alle hielt sich so ein bisschen precious
also an mich gedacht glaube ich einfach
ja dank nehmen dieses bild dann werde
ich mein herzchen steckt ja das stimmt
etwas von dem du damit geschmack so
lecker is tropical marschiert auch
sofort macht ihn auf ich es doch alles
hier ist doch alles zählt auch das passt
doch aber jetzt kommen die grossen pomp
ich habs jetzt wieder gehört ich wusste
dass irgendwann zurückkommen
ich frage mal ist nur ein soziales
aber was machst du jetzt anders weil
mein als dieses mit dem lied posten du
hast es dir damit ein bisschen gescherzt
vertrauen in st
wenn ich meinen feed gesehen habe wusste
ich jetzt einfach so bot das bin ich
das ist so kommt der große melone und
was wird sich ändern nichts wie es war
ich weiß nicht wann ich zurück hole ich
warte einfach weil mein körper sagt
bitte dem programm
ja ich finde halt du musst also ich
würde dir empfehlen ist einfach zu
deiner es ist ja nur ein tool und
plattform und du kannst das ja daraus
machen was du willst leuten freuen
die du willst du kannst das posten was
du willst und wenn du mit dem
unzufrieden des services dann kannst du
es halt ändern
zu sagen wir auch so viele leute unter
meinem video geschrieben wie jahren habe
auch keinen instagram nicht ganz
verstehen und ihre reise immer wieder
noch geschrieben zu benutzen sei falsch
so die haben den die ja sehr künstler
seiten oder you zeichen dingern streckte
wurzellos machst ja aber man fühlt sich
ja auch so also ich kann es aber ich
habe auch so parkraums den folglich hat
weil ich mich in diese sowie heißen
kollegen oder so ich musste folgen weil
es gehört also aber eigentlich will ich
die bilder gesehen aber dafür nicht also
dieser algorithmus aber sperrt sich aber
jeder dass nun noch das so wenn man die
bilder angezeigt kann aber ich leite
ganz bewusst die leute immer nur wo ich
ihn wieder mehr gesehen weil die ich
sehen will sich eigentlich obwohl noch
die was auffällt dass es so schlimm es
hat auch gute seiten
er weiß dass ich meinen mann kannst du
dir noch so ein bisschen programm
mir ist es ja auch bei facebook und über
also wenn du halt nur so komische
scheiße die ganzen anguckt dann wird dir
nur mehr so komische seite 3 weil der
heydt weiße okay dass das ist dass das
möchte den nutzer sehen er bleibt dann
länger auf der plattform
es hat mir irgendwann erzählt dass er
bei facebook die eine zeitlang afg
seiten angeschaut hat einfach nur um zu
checken was da so geht das was und um
die leute einfach so mal mit zufrieden
handel eingestuft hat und seitdem denkt
facebook dass er alles was die auf dem
posten sehen möchte und irgendwelche
navi aber hast du schon eine idee was du
jetzt woanders machen
ich finde es ja sowieso meine medien
kultur hat so für mich der perfekte
gramm account auf dem internet finde ich
und du wirst niemals verraten dass sie
ist jetzt nicht so dass sie szenen aus
irgendwelchen fehlen aus ihr panisch
lang oder sogar ein pakt sondern das ist
einfach so also da ist kein familien 90
prozent ihre mäuse irgend welche videos
wie ihre mäuse irgendwas pressen
ab und zu mal so ein baby verkleidet ist
oder irgendwie so lustig und die hat da
33.000 follower und millionen auf
youtube was ich glaube es geht einfach
darum irgendwie das zu machen worauf man
bock hatte sie hat box videos in ihren
räumen so macht man dann macht sie ja
genau genau und uns völlig okay wenn du
wenn du halt jemand bisher bockhardt
schönes oder webos und dafür brennen
dann macht es auch also das ist jetzt
aber ist jedoch glaube ich mich darum zu
sagen so allen die solche schönen feeds
arme sind fake oder schlecht oder so
wenn du wenn es um dein ding ist in
bockhorst dann macht das einfach aber
wenn es sich nicht wirklich macht dann
ende einfach was tragen
das ist genau das was mich enttäuscht
hat oder wo ich wirklich da ist so echt
wie konnte das passieren
weil die leute sagen ja auf youtube nach
und ich fühle mich eigentlich auch so
recht authentisch und ich fühle mich so
ich mache mein ding ich meine alleine
dass wir beide tempi machen da irgendwie
ist jemand versucht haben schon
naja ok aber ich hatte noch bock
anfangsgehalt gemacht das war auch
irgendwie ja nicht dass man das machen
kann
es war sehr tief man noch nicht wusste
ich kann die wahl über die liebe die man
an bis 28
und ich freue mich wie konnte es mir
passieren dass ich vom anfang des jahres
bis dann so das gemacht habe wie
adipositas abend habe ich auf einer
party von freunden war saß ich da noch
irgendwas fotografien videos posten kann
ich habe zum beispiel was ich komplett
gemacht habe ist dass ich meine
notifications abgestellt also ich krieg
nicht mehr roger nachrichten so ich sehe
halt wenn der 1 oder 2 auf weil nicht
einsperren man kann checken wir
geschrieben hat aber ich habe das nicht
mehr dieses also wenn ihr trinkwasser
verbraucht dann kann er mich anrufen das
kriege ich so weiter aber woods hat nach
ich das wichtigste auf der welt und dann
auch also zum beispiel ich habe es auch
ausgestellt man kann ja so einstellen
dass man natürlich jedes like bekommt
was bei uns ein bisschen viel mehr aber
man kann auch dass man nur die leute die
am folgen das habe ich mal so man ist
geneigt das habe ich auch alles
abgestellt weil am ende des tages so
kann ich ja auch dann noch mal und das
bild gucken und zu gucken achja weiteres
bild gleichfalls mir ist wirklich so
wichtig ist aber einfach also mir manch
auch wenn man zu viel so auch ich hatte
so richtig unglücklich darauf gemacht
nicht unbedingt weil ich gedacht habe
auch all jenen das perfekte leben und
ich nicht sondern einfach weil ich so
viel zeit auch damit verschlechtert habe
also ich hab ja ich sag dann wollen sich
morgen sagen da ja und ich wusste ich
okay ich hab jetzt dass uns das zu tun
aber man ist dann davor auch wenn es in
die kuhle aufgaben nun aussagen immer
faszinierend ein bisschen anstrengend
das heißt einfach nur deutschland
fenster vize richard so dass das
strengste der welt habe ich mich ja
nicht so viel zeit damit vergeudet und
ich hätte so viel produktiver zeigen
können und ich habe einfach teil hab
immer gedacht was mache ich denn ein mix
ist hier so sitze zeit nach halben
stunde ja ich finde mittlerweile ganz
ganz schlimm wenn man so eine
freundesgruppe musikern die alle kennen
und du genau weiß dass eigentlich keiner
wirklich was zu tun also sondern man ist
nur machen weil man irgendwie weil es
halt einfacher als jetzt ist sein handy
scroll als plötzlich zu überleben
vorüber nach halten kannst den mann
gestern abend zum beispiel zusammenhänge
und da hat sich gar keines war am handy
das also ich finde es so dass noch immer
bedenklich wenn zu partys oder tolle
abend wo alles auf instagram fertig
gewesen und elegante die 1000
ja genau ja es gibt ja wenn du dioxin
jetzt besonders viele die komplette
leben dürfen haben die erleben auch die
ganze zeit so besonders glücklich sind
da ich fand zum beispiel wenn ich schon
morgens aus dem bett gefallen haben dass
deutsche oder morgens eine stunde lang
da lag bevor ihr aufgestanden bin ich
muss super dringender toilette
eigentlich aber noch lang und twitter
dann können ja wieder was neues auf
facebook passiert sein muss und wird
besser also man ist dann in diesem look
und könntest dich bekannten tag
wir könnten uns hinsetzen den ganzen tag
länger liga interessiert
ich musste dann auch schon mal wie ist
das denn wenn du auf instagram bis ich
bin so ungefähr zehnmal am tag ab
instagram lesen
habs aktualisiert und immer alles
angucken bis zum letzten bild was ich
schon kannte
und dann ist es klar nachdem eine woche
die trattoria spaß gesagt so ich gucke
die letzte woche komme nicht zurück
rechnet sich nicht
aber so weil ich wenn ich so in alte
gewohnheiten zurück gerutscht während
das so gemacht als ich habe auch größere
gemacht und bis es halt der letzte post
aber auch nicht so war
man kann einfach mit dieser zeit und
jetzt so viel sind man kann nicht
einfach so viel sinnvoller irgendwie
nutzen diese belassen vor allem ich
meinen sie sind alle schönsten sich und
alles gut die leute so einen großen
verstöße insgesamt nicht aber diese
bilder die die werden dein leben
bereiten in die leiste reise genau die
frage ist halt was gibt dir da ist und
nebenbei mir was soll ich habe mich nach
diesem scrollen irgendwie leer gefühlt
und unmotiviert und ausgesaugt und ich
finde auch man hat mangels und bz wieso
den nebeligen kopf habe ich das gefühl
also ich fühle mich danach so vielleicht
kann man die ganze doch sowas start und
habe mich dann
teilweise noch so richtig so so war als
geschäftsmann wieso du guckst du die
ganze zeit brauchen merkt gar nicht dass
und nicht herum passiert und wie die
zeit vergeht und installiert so realität
den realitätsbezug irgendwie bestimmt
ist es wie so eine trance ist mehr als
ob so ein pendler anfang genommen
und deswegen machen das glaube ich auch
so viel so gern weil es halt auch mal
schön ist sich eben von diesem alltag
oder von diesen pflichten und den
zwängen und den verantwortung kam in dem
moment einfach nur so loszureißen weil
man einfach in so einer anderen welt
kurz drin ist aber das problem fertig
wird das ist dass es schnell zu viel
erreicht hat das ist wie so ein
drogenabhängiger dann bringt jeden tag
zu kaufen weil er halt so damit fühle
ich mich besser damit deine familie
realität besser ertragen
ich finde schon dass social media wie so
eine art droge eigentlich ist und die
hat man uns gegeben und habe da schafft
ein podcast mit lakonischen ich sage das
auch und zu zitieren ja das war sowieso
eine drucksystemen und gegeben hat und
eigentlich keiner wirklich weiß was was
die folge sind und was wie man das
richtig dosierten wie man es richtig
verwendet ja was das alles es geht darum
hat die richtige dosis zu füllen
kein kind ja keine angst denn ich weiß
es sich instagram habe ich wann habe ich
instagram installiert mit meinem
youtube-kanal kleiner sein soll ich vor
fünf jahren wahrscheinlich auch so
bewusst auf dem weg zur irgendwie habe
ich mir schon mal wieder genannte videos
ich hab das war bei mir so okay wir sind
youtube kanal youtuber sagen fragt mich
braucht resonanz ich weiß gar nicht wen
ich nicht lieber geworden wäre ob ich
dann instagram hätte weil ich glaube wir
sind gerade so also bestimmt auch nicht
doch im november mittlerweile viele
was anderes erlebnis in die 30er seit
wann ist ein instagram gerade so wie es
jetzt ist
also es weil ich weiß wo die ersten zwei
jahre war instagram er nicht irgendwie
darüber nicht gesprochen
so wird man hatte dass er war ein paar
bilder drauf da ich glaube ich ist es so
krass geworden mit stars na ja ich
glaube schon weil sie dadurch wirklich
so dieses nicht nur dieses bilder kosten
sondern auch so dieses ok post jetzt was
ich jetzt mache die leute müssen was ich
jetzt so er wird deswegen auch snapshot
funktioniert
ich habe gehört natürlich geht bach
runter oder sind habe ich hier weiter
ich habe das auch schon verlängerung
gelöscht
bei mir war das dann auch immer man zu
viel weil da hat mir gesagt ich hab's
löschen ist das geschäft aber das war
als ich hatte ja auch so eine phase von
halma oder so habe ich echt so in das
tor war wie so meint del die blogging
ich habe das auch aus dem wald
angefahren und da wirklich sowieso
eindruck gemacht und die ganze story
halt kommt es an nur einem tag begleitet
und es war immer einfach zu extrem
schreier dass er viel zu viel weshalb
auch ein leben für dich leben und du
wirklich alles mit allen teilen oder
wirklich auf alles feedback haben sind
wenn du willst auf moment dich und jedes
mal wenn du jetzt im moment auch teilt
sich geht was von dem moment verloren
weil du hast deine kamera und handy
ausgepackt und du ja es nimmt einfach
ganz oft was weg und oft kannst ja auch
sachen ganze festhalten kannst du nicht
so wirklich gefühle und also ist fest
rasse diese diese doku vom kollektiv
gesehen
[Musik]
die ist da sind sie auf der berlin
fashion um die begleiten
13 uhr machen wir so schnell nicht
gesehen
die eine ist germany's next topmodel
kandidat gewesen und diese dort habe ich
noch vor dem löschen gesehen und ich
glaube es war der letzte stoße ich so
und ich hab auch letzte zimmer falschen
studio in ihr beispiel 70 influenza
genannt nicht so
eigentlich bin ich kenne flächen welche
bei instagram ich mache youtube-videos
und bin eigentlich youtuber wenn
überhaupt und er hat sie mir dass ihr
seid jetzt alle in führen zwar ob jetzt
und dann wartet dann kam dann erst
wieder schlimme nicht ins internet wo
ich hasse es ist wirklich so ich finde
das nicht fair - es gibt halt so leute
die mich brauchen diesen begriff
software influenza simple and
kriegskosten es keine hilfe sei aber
letztendlich so ist es ich finde den
begriff nicht schwimmen
denn wenn also klar negativ sagte aber
ich persönlich sehe mich negativ und
deswegen so was ich halt macht es halt
leute auch beeinflussen und nicht
unbedingt in dem kleine dass ich sein
auch in diesem angesteuerte kaufen
sondern halt hey überlegt mal was ihr
gerade mit zum spiel ja mach das doch
auch mit den fluren sie muss nicht immer
negativ sein beeinflussen was ist denn
wenn du zum beispiel ein rapper bist
oder ein schauspieler der auf instagram
ganze zeit deutet alles teilt das
alleinsein
du kannst ja mehr wenn du musst ja nicht
ich entscheide mit influenza oder rapper
oder youtube konnte vieles ok ja das
sind und weibliche comedians und das und
ich bin köcheln und ich bin dazu klingt
wie so eine kampagne erwarten so stark
ich bin mutter eine person wurmen und
technik und alleinerziehend und stark
ich kann mir so richtig verabschieden
und seine frau mitte 30
vor seiner grauen wand und neben ihr
kommen so die worte so reingeht muss und
dass man dieses und und sich dann
richtig stolz oder aber ich glaube auch
ich glaube ich sehe im moment auch so
als schlimm begriff weil niemand der
sich mit dieser branche wirklich
auseinander rap tanz nur du halt mit
bekommt so meine beste freundin zum
beispiel die krieg endlich youtube die
weiß es ist sie guckt sich das papier
kanäle an wasser und dann hat er sie in
die usa
also die grippe man hat noch kurz
gelacht weil ich bin jetzt auch
influenza weil das heute alle wir
kriegen nicht in diesem gelben
mitspielen so ein abhängiger begriff für
die das ist auch so ein influenza also
objektiv gehört aber ich glaube das ist
genial
es ist ein model das ist auch so ein
bisschen so hd belächeln das aber
gleichzeitig sehr
er kenne er kein model sein nicht mehr
klappt wird also schon aber auch nicht
so also den flotteren man braucht auch
nicht weder talent in manchen bereitest
du mal überlegt überlegt hat nach
letzten es gibt ja mittlerweile so viele
ich meinen als wir anfang juli zu machen
wie viele große insel youtube account
haben sich 20 und 20 jahre so
mittlerweile hast du das gefühl du
entdeckst ja immer wie ein kanal wurde
sagt wer ist die person eine million
und dann ist in der letzten zeit
gedanken gekommen dass nicht jeder
erfolgreich wird überlegt macht wie
viele menschen enttäuscht
youtube-videos manga und verkaufen sie
zu jeder mit sonst war und jeder freund
von dem bis zu 2000 euro an ist auch wer
instagram so finde ich es gibt so viele
instagram irgendwie so 20 bis 50.000
abos haben und es ist einfach so wenn
wird blattfarben ja da sagt gutmann wo
das frühstück ich habe es mir selbst
vergangen wollen
ich wills schon wiederholt das ding ist
vorbei der verschärfungen ja im neue
leute
das dachte ich mir auch aber ganz
ehrlich macht einfach so ich habe auch
meinen ersten nacht nach diesen solche
lieder war auch das erste ich bin wieder
zurück übrigen sich marco live und das
war s so weiß es nicht hinnehmen dass
nicht so einfach ich habe auch über die
zogen muss jetzigen trasse
es geht einfach darum muss ich das
worauf du lust hast und mindesten riesig
das bild mit ankündigen uns macht es
sinn wenn du einfach nur einen fehler
geschossen
dann macht es auch so die leute wie
finde ich gut so wie du bist also wenn
ihr mehr instagram wiederhole dann war
es euch was dagegen zusammen
lösche alle kommentare sowie wer macht
das auch nicht dass du jetzt koste wenn
ihr mit uns das nächste mal teatime
haben wurden wir über gossip in youtube
reden schreibt mir kommen
[Musik]
ich bin kein gott zum küchendienst
weiterträgt in eine große krise baby und
julian haben war das ist so geil wie das
die zuschauer niemals als erfahren
werden diese ganzen sachen die sich
untereinander ihre ruhe lässt
die youtuber sich untereinander also
zielen
ja ja wir hoffen entschuldigung für
diese chaotische generation dass der
erste teil nicht dabei war doch alles
gut in reports es schwierig den knopf zu
drücken wollte ist echt nicht einfach
nach fehlt ja ich finde aber wie gesagt
ich den ton an ich habe da tun sich
einmal mit rhetorischen komplett toren
aus
daran hab ich schon richtig
nein du kannst sehr schön auf instagram
randstunden bist hast du dran hat schon
dein verschwendet aber du hast irgendwas
gemacht so was ich esse ich vor anregt
aber wenn du drehst du hast davon aus
der energie- und so reingestellt hat es
dann noch mal gedreht ja ja so sorge
und hier ich muss dir noch ganz viele
sachen erzählt da waren wir jetzt die
kamera stand